no
y llegué a irak en 2003 el régimen de
sadam husein acababa de ser derrocado y
en ese momento había una mezcla de
esperanza en la población
y no hay que olvidar que los soldados
estadounidenses fueron recibidos con
rosas al comienzo pero los atentados
comenzaron a multiplicarse un mes antes
de mi llegada
dejaron un saldo de 22 muertos entre
ellos sergio vieira de mello el
representante de la onu dímelo
qué acción había entonces una mezcla de
esperanza y a la vez un comienzo de
radicalización después dijo vivir y
luego la situación siguió desmejorando
me citó la situación decidió estoy
dejando
fue el propio ministro quien escribió
una carta para indicar la dirección a
seguir yo participé en su redacción
sabía porque me encontraba en irak lo
sabía claramente
el propósito de mi misión era a la vez
contribuir a la estabilidad de irak a la
calma de cultivo y por otra parte a
restablecer la influencia de francia
que era muy difícil porque los
estadounidenses eran hostiles con
nosotros por habernos opuesto a la
invasión a irak
y aquí los mismos iraquíes muchos de
ellos habían regresado del exilio tras
decenas de años por fuera estaban
convencidos de que francia estaba aliada
con sadam husein por intereses
económicos y hasta de 1.030 delante en
todo caso es lo que los estadounidenses
les decían a las nuevas autoridades
iraquíes y de ahí la enorme desconfianza
con la que nos veían indicios
los partidos iraquíes que se oponían a
la presencia estadounidense nos recibían
bien nuestra ventaja en irak era que
hablábamos con todo el mundo
absolutamente con todo el mundo excepto
los terroristas digo pues ya digo pero
debo reconocer que incluso hablamos con
grupos bastante radicales que teníamos
entendido eran cercanos a la resistencia
me refiero también a las autoridades
religiosas suníes con quienes
manteníamos relaciones muy cercanas
este trabajo bien labrado nos permitió
restablecer poco a poco cierta
influencia en irak los estadounidenses
eran quienes tenían el poder hacían las
reglas y daban lecciones de democracia
ah sí
pero eran ellos mismos quienes
manipulaban los hilos de las marionetas
que estaban en ese entonces en el poder
en irak no no y ahora qué
así que si esa idea nació porque
estábamos convencidos de que no era
posible estabilizar afganistán sin
contar con una parte importante de la
población tenía
tiempo de la perdición y por ello había
que facilitar una solución que incluyera
a todas las partes ya todas las
sensibilidades inclusive a los talibán y
congénitas de un país unido y se mojan y
ccoo porque no hay que olvidar que los
talibán son gente extremadamente radical
pero más radical todavía ésta es al
qaeda
el cairo y nutrición entonces nuestra
convicción era que no se podía tener un
afganistán estable sin dialogar con los
talibán
es lo que llamamos el proceso de
chantilly hubo varias reuniones para
sorpresa de todos mientras que todo el
mundo nos decía que nunca lograríamos
reunirnos con ellos en la misma mesa de
negociación pues sí vinieron
en todo caso en la última reunión de
gente importante ellos estaban allí pero
no fue más allá porque hay que reconocer
que ya en esa época los estadounidenses
que al principio no creían y pensaban
que esto era diversión para nosotros no
tomaban en serio lo que hacíamos
pero cuando comenzaron a ver que
comenzaba a funcionar entonces se
sintieron ofendidos
seguro que yo nunca lo es una
oportunidad que se perdió para un
término indio ahora todavía no habíamos
iniciado la parte fuerte de las
negociaciones pero habíamos logrado que
todos aceptaran incluyendo los talibán
un cierto número de principios que te
han puesto a su vice que tu mundo
lo importante de chantilly era que todo
el mundo estaba allí y no sólo eso los
talibán no estaban solos uno no negocia
con los talibán allí estaban los
diferentes bandos afganos la llegada de
los talibán a parís hizo que dos mundos
que casi nunca o nunca se habían
encontrado lo hicieron